So let's first look at what tools we have at our disposal when looking at storyboarding.
So you can see here the typical storyboarding workflow.
We may have had some kind of idea and then we're going to some kind of previous department
and then go through the various departments and iterate on that through the pre-production
cycle.
So the storyboards here are created with some kind of hand-drawn drawings created with
the various 3D packages and then we iterate on them through this cycle.
So we go through story dev, production design, interblocking, create some form of story reel
from that.
Maybe we go back into blocking based on some feedback that we get and then through to the
editorial.
Now, the interesting thing about the approach that we're looking at today is that it's
a much more iterative process through each of the different cycles that we're looking
at.
We're constantly kind of iterating based on the storyboards that we can see within the
different shot setups and the way we kind of construct this whole pipeline here.
So by introducing the E-Pars and Iliad tools from Praxinus, we will move the pre-production
workflow for story and layout almost entirely into Unreal Engine.
So you can see the kind of more purple based icons where we would have traditionally kept
this offline from Unreal Engine where you can see now we've got some storyboard via the
use of the plugin which we'll jump into in a few moments here.
You can see that the storyboarding is able to be done in Unreal.
We now have modeling tools and with the Iliad plugin as well and some rigging tools, we
were able to do some production design inside of Unreal Engine.
We're also just able to block whether it be performance capture, level layout and the
assembly tools using a sequence of which we'll jump into.
You can see there's a whole host of breakpoints in the cycle where we can have just this live
iteration via the use of Unreal Engine and some of the additional plugins that we'll
be looking at.
And so hopefully you'll be able to see that that whole cycle and process is much more
iterative.
So let's jump into what that looks like now.